the bitcoin world would argue uh
decentralization's really important for
security obviously bitcoin is the most
decentralized network in the world it's
the most uh secure computer network in
the world uh as you mentioned earlier it
has proven to be a fantastic store value
over a long period of time uh you know
decade plus but it sounds like you're
actually making a different argument
which is like maybe the ultimate goal of
some of this technology is not
decentralization uh because the security
component of it isn't nearly as
important as the efficiency like if you
think of those two as a trade-off so you
get security or you get efficiency at
the layer one it sounds like you're
making know the efficiencies where
there's tons of value to unlock yeah i'm
not sure there's a ton of value to
decentralize the us dollar if people
want to send us dollars they could do it
more uh more effectively yeah we've seen
that we've seen people try to do that
before
but
yeah for the bitcoin world that is the
most important thing decentralization is
king like we're protect bitcoin is just
a child safety lock we're protecting
ourselves from ourselves and that's why
it exists and that's why it's going to
be
tens of trillions hundreds of trillions
of dollar asset
but for the us dollar i mean businesses
want to send us dollars places like
that's the world we live in currently
and you have a way more efficient way to
do it there's no need to be cosmic brand
about this i mean a dollar is a dollar
there's going to be centralization on
the back end now if that entire kind of
regime is going to fall it's a different
conversation but yeah there's no need to
decentralize
you just need reliable kind of proof of
reserves you need an easy on on-ramp for
that and you get more people involved in
the ecosystem that's good for bitcoin
ultimately which is a decentralized
store of value that we have you
mentioned that bitcoin is a child safety
lock what is bitcoin as a child safety
lock mean it
it's you know it's it's just there's a
fixed money supply in bitcoin and we
can't bring ourselves to do that it's
like that scene in limitless where he
says yeah you know there's no there's no
safeguards for human nature you know why
don't we just like crack a beer and live
off the interest and we can't do that uh
that's that's the innovation of bitcoin
is we are preventing ourselves from
inflating the currency there's no way to
change the currency value um
that is a child safety law and that's
why it's valuable it's just protecting
humanity from its its worst inclinations
so i think you myself many people are
watching this they get that do the
corporations yet understand this or are
they so focused on efficiency and the
kind of the conservative approach to
their balance sheets that that is a a
secondary thought they may have later
but right now they're just focused on
dollars the truth i would love to have a
company that like 24 7 focuses on
bitcoin on the balance sheet
but it wouldn't be much of a company
like we wouldn't do a series a we have
that as an option we kind of you know
nudge people like hey
bitcoin's great right
so we're gonna we're gonna do our part
there just to be clear but what they
care about is 24 7 settlement right now
of us dollars low fee transacting uh
things they can't get from fedwire and
ach things they can't get from their
legacy bank accounts so we are at meow
we believe we've built a better solution
for them and that's
largely on the u.s dollar rails with the
ability to buy bitcoin seamlessly from
that same account what about things like
payroll like one of the big problems in
the legacy financial system is that
people only get paid uh every other week
so you know twice a month uh or once a
month and there's tons and tons of
studies that show uh i think it was in
2019 the top four banks made like eight
billion dollars of overdraft fees yep
and when you go and you actually analyze
those overdraft fees in many cases it's
not that people don't have the money
it's that uh their grocery bill came in
on the 12th then their car payment came
in on the 13th netflix says on the 14th
bam they get paid on the 15th but they
actually overdrafted on 13th and 14th
because the paycheck hadn't hit right
and so we were simply able to pay people
at the end of every day it would
drastically eliminate one the overdraft
fees and that kind of whole part of the
legacy banking system but also two is it
would give people more economic freedom
and flexibility and so is that something
that stable coins or kind of these
crypto rails could help solve yeah
certainly you can't really do that in
legacy finance i mean it's not it's not
a good ux things like layer twos can
help with that right now the gas is too
high to do like micro transactions on a
fraction of a usdc
um but things like layer twos can help
and you can even do that you know
partially in a database partially on
chain but yeah you're certainly right
that's that's a real use case like when
we talk about real use cases i think
stable coins are dominating for legacy
finance uh stable coins are our king and
we we see their adoption about to blow
up in a good way and
i think that's ultimately very very good
for bitcoin i mean it gets everyone
thinking about this space and they start
thinking okay this is how i'm using my
payment rails there's a much easier way
to buy bitcoin now with this um and
that's that's kind of where we plug into
that too